foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money I am your host Jade warshaw joined
by the incomparable Doctor John deloney
doctor I think I'm there's many many
more comparable the infamous Dr John
deloney how about that it feels good man
I like it love it take it all right guys
we are talking we're hanging out talking
about again your life your money give us
a call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five we'll talk
about whatever it is that's going on in
your life all right let's go to Marisol
in Chicago Illinois what's going on
Marisol
hi thank you for having me on so with
all this commotion going on with student
loans as we know there's going to the
interest rates will start to hit in
September that's right I have
seventy thousand dollars in loans I have
in my savings account just enough to
almost pay them all oh
and the problem is that I'm one of those
that have been in school for long enough
to probably be a surgeon and I'm almost
done I'll be done next balls thank god
um but I'm paying it cash good for you
so I I did not get any more loans my
only thing is that about 45
000 of the loans I have to pay off is
unsubsidized okay and those rates are
quite high and they're fixed yeah
they're about majority are about six
percent and although I had the money in
my savings should I just pay it all off
and start over I just well that's gonna
be broke let's walk through this because
it it may be as drastic as that or it
may not let's make sure we've got uh
some other things in place before we
just jump to taking all the cash as you
walk through this can I say one thing
real quick and then I'm gonna turn back
over to Jade I I can't help myself a
comment on this
the way you just described that is
indicative of how the entire country is
dealing with this issue and I is it okay
if I just call you out and we're friends
we'll still be we'll still be best
friends after this
that's go ahead the way you described it
if I pay all this off I'm gonna feel
like I'm broke I know right I want you
to know you're broke right now you're
broke right now you're broke it feels
good
but you owe 70
000 yeah okay so I don't want you to
feel like it's gonna feel a different
kind of broke I get that but I don't
want you to pretend in your mind or do
some mental gymnastics that like I'm all
good here
but if I do this and I take care of the
thing that I said I was going to take
care of that suddenly I'm going to be in
the worst financial position you're in a
scary position right now as is okay I'll
turn over to Jake John such a good point
that you just made and Marisol we're not
picking on you girl we're talking about
the whole world this is basic math
if you have seventy thousand dollars
minus seventy thousand dollars in debt
you have zero dollars you're broke so
even if you feel like you have money
because you got savings you still broke
if you got the debt so basic math
session over Marisol back to you
um let's go back and see um
foundationally if we're in a good
position to actually pay off these loans
so my first question to you is do you
have any other debt besides the student
loans
no I don't very very good uh my second
question to you is regarding your
savings this seventy thousand dollars is
this all the money in the world that you
have
this is all I have liquid okay and then
the money that's non-liquid how is that
invested
is it stocks I have money it's stocks on
401K okay how much do you have in the
single stocks
not much of maybe five thousand so not
not much there five thousand well it's
significant when we're talking about
student loans and savings okay so here's
where I'm at with you
um the way we teach and you you sound
like you're kind of familiar with this
um we would pay off all of our debt in
baby step two using the debt snowball
which for you as your student loans and
then quickly after that we would want to
get three to six months of expenses
saved and that's kind of I want you to
know that that's what we're shooting
towards if we take this money to pay off
your debt okay and in this case I truly
believe that you need to pay off this
debt
I think that you are going to experience
a freedom that you've never felt before
I think you're going to want to rip your
shirt off and run through a Countryside
because that's how good it's going to
feel to be debt free
um and then you've got you know you've
got this 5K in stocks you could keep it
in there or you could liquidate it and
put that into your you know start
building up your three to six months
fund again
um and before you know it you're not
gonna have any payments no debt before
you know it you're going to have this
three to six months built up again and
this time the math will actually math
for you and you'll actually have money
how does that sound
logical and scary yes and that is
correct that is the correct answer John
talk to the scary part
it's scary you're going to find yourself
you have this artificial cushion that
you're that you rest your head on every
night which me which is cash in the bank
and you pretend I don't have this
humongous hole right outside my back
back door which is seventy thousand
dollars of of student loan debt and also
I just want to speak to something that
that Jay just said
oh
I heard it once um at a live event a
speaker we go to Live Events all the
time and I heard a speaker say something
that it's rare that I walk away in
something a sentence that is sputtered
just lodges itself in my soul almost
tattooed itself on my chest and here was
the sentence whatever responsibilities
you Outsource at some point will be used
against you
if you Outsource
um I'm just never gonna worry I'm just
going to have instacart bring my food
I'm just gonna have instacart bring my
food I'm gonna have instacart bring my
food and you don't know where your food
comes from at some point covet happens
in the grocery store stop and everybody
goes whoa what do we do now right in
this case I can promise you
it's human nature it's human history all
of it
the government will not wipe away let's
say they figure out how to do some
gymnastics and they knock these loans
away and some other loans away they will
come back to you with their handout and
say we want ours now
whether that's in taking power from you
taking autonomy from you demanding votes
back demanding higher taxes back this
whole idea that they've got to come
rescue us is not a rescue it's an roi'd
investment on their part because they're
going to come back for their piece of
Flesh and I want no part of it and again
I had six figures in loans Jade had six
figures and Loans I promise you I did
not know what I was signing
and I signed my name on the piece of
paper that said if you help me go to
college I'll pay you back
and it was a matter of selling my house
and moving into a residence hall it was
a matter of Integrity for me and my wife
had said we said we would pay this back
even though we were children we didn't
know what you're doing we're gonna pay
this back and so there's an Integrity
Integrity part to this and let's say you
pay this all off and next weekend all
the loans in America go away
I still think you did the right thing
and I still think you're gonna walk a
two inches taller you're not gonna have
seventy thousand dollars in the bank
that's for sure no question about that
will you be scared absolutely yes
but you're gonna be able to breathe
you're gonna always be able to know I
did the right thing and when someone
says the next time the government says
you can't you can't you can't you'll be
able to go yeah I can come on yes I can
I can because I did already that's what
I'm talking about go out Marisol pay off
these loans and breathe in that good air
that free air that's what I'm talking
about I love seeing people make the
choice to get free this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on guys you're
listening to the Ramsey Show I'm Jade
warshaw joined by John deloney and uh
this show is all about you guys it's all
about what you're facing on a day-to-day
basis when it comes to your money when
it comes to your mental health when it
comes to your career and that's what
we're discussing on the show it's a
call-in show call in the numbers triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and we'll chop it up with you we'll help
you sort it out and figure out what's
the next best step for you uh and that
being said
we've got you know a lot going on in the
news right now John with student loans
and everything going on like that and um
today uh as of hours ago Biden came
through and issued yet another
um executive order of some sort yeah
executive order of sorts yes issuing yet
more forgiveness for borrowers which in
the past we've been we've been seeing
these trickle through you know things
for
um disabled folks vets people who their
school went out of business and you know
I'm definitely not mad at that the one
that came through today 39 billion
dollars of forgiveness for around 804
000 borrowers and so of course
everybody's like Jade what does this
mean you know is this for everybody is
this for me you know what does this mean
and I'm like well if you really look at
it this is for folks John who signed up
for these income driven repayment plans
uh you might see it labeled as IDR and
you're like what the heck is an IDR plan
income driven repayment plans and these
are people John who have been paying
their student loans for the past 20 25
years
because they were told if you make this
payment for 20 years and you make x
amount of qualifying payments you'll at
the end of the road you'll have
forgiveness
25 years John
wow You'll have forgiveness and then you
get there you're sweaty you're tired
your body's aching your back is broken
and there was nothing and they say nah
we changed our mind and now finally
these folks are getting their money so
hey it's a good day for our parents
right if they have student loans for
real but
here's here's where I'm at and here's
for me where I think is just
it's just painful these these plans that
are for these folks 25 years in they're
like finally I'm getting my money these
are the same plans John that they want
borrowers today to get into because
student loan payments are coming up
you're gonna start have to start making
your payments in October right hey
we don't want you guys to have to pay
too much you know we don't want you
uncomfortable so why don't you jump into
one of these income driven repayment
plans uh the new one I believe is called
the save plan y'all can correct me if
I'm wrong they're always changing the
acronyms on this but the idea is hey you
can jump on the site you're
automatically enrolled when payments
come back and you can just jump on the
site and go ahead and um you can go
ahead and submit your own estimate of
your income and and we're not we're not
going to require any qualifying
documents to see if it's right so people
just gonna make up a number I make 30
grand and I can pay 15 come on and
that'll be good and just kick that just
kick that can down the road for 20 25 30
years and at the end you know there'll
be a little Buckle of gold at that
rainbow except that in in
24 years we're going to have gone
through what six presidential
transitions come on 12 Senate
transitions who knows man and with the
data coming out yesterday there was
um folks are beginning to talk more and
more about the psychological the mental
health aspect of owing people money yes
and it it is sleep inhibitory it messed
up her sleep it messed up your
relationships it makes you not want to
live makes you don't want to be married
it makes all these issues and so what
we're saying is I want you to be unwell
for 20 years go to the College of your
choice and that you feel most
impassionate about and study what you
want to study and just give us a little
bit every month choose to be miserable
yeah and not be fully present because
you have this hovering over your head
this black cloud as the article said
hovering over your head and then in 20
25 years if you're lucky we'll take it
from you yeah I mean John you you
painted a beautiful picture
um in an earlier segment there was a
caller who had a certain number of
students she had seventy thousand
dollars of student loan debt and she had
seventy thousand dollars of savings and
she was feeling some type of way about
using the savings to pay off the debts
project words were if I pay this off I'm
gonna feel like I'm broke
yeah and I was like you are bro you are
broke and like the picture that you
painted I thought was brilliant and I
kind of wanted to elaborate that it it
really is when when you have the money
sitting there to pay these loans guys
and you're not paying them it is like
you live in this beautiful home right
and and it's everything you want it's
modern it's it's got all the right
surfaces you know what I'm saying it's
got It's got the marble countertops but
outside right outside your home is a
black giant black hole desolation
destruction and you just ignore it every
day you have to stay in the house you
gotta stay in the house you can't go
anywhere you can't go outside because
but your brain knows it's there your
reality yeah your brain knows the
reality right that you owe the
government
this much money and I just
for me guys and I know you guys are like
Jade wow you don't have to yell about it
Jade or you're doing the most Jade and
and it's for you the the reason I get
mad about this is I care about you I
want the best for you I know how that
feels I I know how it feels to not be
able to sleep at night I know how it
feels to have that effect on your
marriage the way you work all the
decisions that you make are so that you
can pay bills that's that's a load of
crap man that's for the birds and I
don't want that for you the way I feel
about this is there are so many things
that want you to think that that has the
power but that's not true you have the
power but some of you guys are so
um I can't say that on the radio some of
you guys are so intent on being right
instead of being happy you'd rather be
right that the government owes me this
and they're the ones that will take care
of this mess and they need to figure it
out but I'm trying to give you the
answer that's going to make you happy
and give you peace and give you freedom
and that's you taking back your power
you taking back your autonomy right you
being able to just financially
self-regulate on your own instead of
depending on the government instead of
depending on credit cards instead of
depending on all those other external
factors to do what you can do for
yourself and I if you don't get nothing
else from this understand I want you to
be free I know you can be free and I
know you have inside of yourself the
power to be free period period preach
man end of sentence
it hit me last night
um I had just gotten home from from a
long walk by myself and it hit me every
single thing in the ecosystem that young
people and young adults are growing up
in right now and quite honestly older
adults too yeah is that you can't
you're too um you've got some kind of
mental health something or other so
you're never going to be able to have a
normal relationship a normal job a
number or whatever yeah you've you've
got some sort of disability you're never
going to be enough you owe people money
and you are too un unable you will never
be able to pay this up because you're
weak and you're not strong enough you
don't worry we got you we got you and
slowly but surely our ability our
responsibility our belief in our self
and confidence which doesn't come from
thinking it comes from doing all that
erodes because we begin to Outsource
every little bit to the government to
this other person to the bank to the
local person saying oh you can't do that
either let me just Pat you on the head
I'll take care of it for you and we are
giving away our souls and it was this
moment of
I I can't be more proud to be a part of
a team that just looks at everybody
where you whether you're a
multi-millionaire or whether you are a
single mom with two kids trying to
figure out how to breathe that we look
you in the eye and we treat you with
enough dignity and respect to look you
now and say you can too I know that's
right and that voice has just been
stolen from us it has to the point to
where people John they get a little bit
angry or they're super angry they get
offended almost that we would imply that
they can do it on their own that's right
it's become almost an insult 100 you
should read the comments online it is
it's it's not almost it is it's a sense
of disempowerment you can't you can't
you never will be able to yeah
somebody's got a bit come bail you out
I'm still haunted by um what the great
micro said a couple years ago during
covet when he said the great tragedy of
covet was we told 300 million Americans
hey just go home you're not essential we
don't need you we'll just mail checks
got to see in a psychological experiment
what happens when you have no purpose
and you just go home and they just mail
checks we all went crazy that's right
not the way to health and and it's not
the way to well hear the message you are
essential in the quest to Freedom
you're the secret sauce you can do it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show
we're back again taking your calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go straight to the phone
lines we got Ed from Nyc New York City
what's going on Ed
hey guys how's it going uh thanks for
taking my call thank you for calling how
can we help
yeah so I just graduated uh with a
masters I decided to take my first job
near home to move in with my parents and
save money but the commute is uh pretty
tough I don't have much time like
outside of work and like commuting uh I
don't really want to rent out there it's
pretty expensive and uh potentially like
renting's a waste of money I'm wondering
if I should just kind of like suck it up
and continue commuting or run closer to
work or even maybe buy a house and what
kind of work do you do man
uh mechanical engineering aerospace
engineering specifically so why why why
do your job in the most expensive place
in America to live
I mean that's where all the engineering
jobs are the other options like LA or
San Francisco
I mean there's other places of course
but uh this is also uh kind of a smart
company and uh just hoping I can move up
fast so except can I throw one wrench in
there
yeah sure you live with your mom
yeah
can you afford you live with your mom
dude are you making money now that you
have your job are you making enough
money forget renting for a get buying
for just a second forget how you're
living are you making enough to live on
your own
in in the place that you would need to
live to be close to work
yeah I wouldn't be saving much but yeah
okay so what I would suggest is like
John very eloquently put getting out of
Mama's house and I would find something
that you can rent until you're able to
buy
so when you're renting just to rent and
you ain't got no plan and you're just
you know then you could say oh I'm just
throwing money down the drain but when
you have a plan and you're saying no I
have an you know an intentional end to
this and it's serving a purpose then
you're not throwing money down the drain
you are being smart is really what that
boils down to and here's what it looks
like to pull apart these variables here
um the reason I asked you if you have to
live there you said yes to do the thing
I want to do I have to live in one of
three of the most expensive places in
America to live okay
so that that variable is covered so it's
off the table I'm not gonna not live in
San Francisco Los Angeles or New York
so that means you have to own the other
variables where am I going to live
what's this job in this place going to
cost me for you it's going to cost you a
couple hours of living at Mom's house
and and having to live with your mom and
having to commute or it's going to cost
you extra money in rent
and so it's it's kind of like you want
to have all of it work out where I want
to work where I want to work and have
the money to do whatever it is I want to
do it's just not the reality
and so just make peace with renting for
a season how old are you Ed
uh just turned 24. 24. yeah I mean
I'll be honest and I'm not gonna lie
about this I kind of am a little salty
about folks who have a good enough
relationship with their parents that
they can live at home and save some
money for a while because I I wouldn't
have been able to do it it would have
just been I tried for one month and
after one month my dad came in and goes
hey I'll pay your your first month's
rent and I was like bye Felicia we're
gone okay I was gone and so Ed I mean I
I think you know you've had this
opportunity to stay with your mom save
some extra dollars that's great that
served you well I do think it's time for
you to get out on your own at 24.
especially since you do have this job
and since you've said yeah I could get I
could get a place you know even if you
want to get some roommates and you know
to make it a little bit cheaper because
again when you're renting let's clarify
you're kind of camping right this is not
renting living in luxury you're trying
to save money so I wouldn't say to rent
the most expensive place or rent your
dream house I'm not saying that I'm
saying camp for a while save up the
money and then reevaluate because like
to John's point you might be like hey to
actually buy I might choose to live in a
different state I might choose to live
somewhere less expensive so take it one
step at a time but right now we're
renting we're saving we're camping as
renters right and that's what I would
suggest what do you think I mean so
here's where I've seen it in in my world
I've seen friends of mine who were on
the they were looking for a tenure track
Professor job and of course they start
with the Ivy League schools they start
with the fancier schools and in their
particular discipline there's just no
jobs open for one year or two years then
they find themselves getting an offer at
a smaller school that isn't a huge name
name in a smaller town and that goes
against I'm a city person I went to
college in Los Angeles I went to grad
school in New York that's just who I am
and then a couple years later they're
like oh gosh dude I get to sleep and I
like I walked to the supermarket and I'm
a part of this small community and so it
does it when you start putting all the
variables on the table what was
important for me was to say I want this
kind of life
and I want to do this kind of work and
now I'm going to reverse engineer where
I do that not let the geography dictate
the life I'm leading if you want to do
that that's all good I'm going to live
in the I know who people I've Got
Friends I will live in New York Until
the End of Time cool you're going to
live in 400 square feet for 5 000 a
month and and and whatever it is that's
right that's just life that's the life
you chose awesome be happy with it just
don't choose a life and then be
frustrated
buy your own choices that's right that's
a good good call out Ed thanks for the
call hopefully we were able to give you
some direction there um in the meantime
let's take a look at Chicago Illinois
where we got Natasha on the line what's
going on Natasha
hi hey happy Friday happy Friday what's
going on
so my question is for Dr John deloney I
hear you guys talk a lot about
boundaries and I want to set one with my
family and extended family but I'm
afraid that they're not going to listen
to it what can I do without severing the
relationship what's that what are they
asking you to do that you don't want to
do
they are my parents are pressuring me to
stop renting because I'm throwing my
money away and move into a mobile home
claiming that I can save a little bit on
the monthly payment I know I love
America we're the best please pay off my
debt and make no clue I've made it loud
and clear I have taken Financial Peace
University I know the steps verbatim how
old are you and I'm currently stuff too
I'm 28 turning 29 in a couple weeks okay
I want you to repeat after me okay okay
they
they do not
do not get a vote
get a vote I've heard that too the
conversation is over there conversations
over there so here's the cool thing
do you work for them
no do you owe them money
kinda
get that paid off as though it was a
foreign country coming for you pay it
off ASAP
debt
it's the last debt on the list oh okay
how about this who cares
they don't get a vote
they can run their and listen they're
they're your parents they're supposed to
give you their insights and opinions
because they know everything everything
and you're the one living your life and
so when they say you know you're just
throwing money away and you should be
moving into a trailer park home that's
going to depreciate so fast your head
will spin off sideways you could say man
thank you so much I appreciate that
insight
hold on you can just leave
if somebody chooses
to not respect me
then I get to choose to not be in their
presence
if somebody chooses to affirmatively
disrespect me to not treat me with
dignity even if we degree man I disagree
all the time me and Dave disagree about
a lot of stuff we just agree disagree
but our disagreements especially once
behind closed doors are always done with
we respect each other because he's a
smart guy he knows I'm a smart guy he
knows I love people and I love my faith
and he does too and so we're on the same
team we're just we just disagree with
stuff you're not going to treat me with
respect then I have a choice that I'm
going to walk away
and the way I like to say this is if
somebody chooses to treat me with
disrespect and somebody chooses to take
my dignity from me
over a simple something as trivial as an
opinion or the way I'm choosing to
better myself financially then they are
choosing to not be in a relationship
with me and that is so harsh and it's so
hard I want you to practice saying hey I
appreciate you guys hey I'm gonna head
out
what you're leaving yeah I'm gonna head
out y'all have a great week guys I love
y'all and then just go and just go
you've heard what they have to say and
as the great uh
Bye Felicia Bye Felicia that's all I'm
saying
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all right all right you guys are
listening to the Ramsay show where we
have a conversation about your life your
money what's going on in your world I'm
Jade warshaw joined by number one
best-selling author John deloney how are
we doing doing good man uh give us a
call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five and as always
I want to remind you if you are a new
listener and you are interested in just
learning more about what it is that
we're talking about on this show we talk
about so many different Financial
Concepts uh on a daily basis here you
might hear us use phrases that you're
not quite familiar with you might hear
us talk about baby steps and you're not
quite sure well what is baby step three
what is baby step five
um go to ramseysolutions.com and click
on that get started button and we're
going to help you figure out the next
best right step for you on your
financial Journey uh and that's going to
be based on where you are today we like
to meet folks where they're at put the
cookies right there look we say put the
cookies on the bottom shelf so sometimes
John I need to just leave a trailer
cookie crumbs on the floor for some of
these folks because I want you guys to
get it I want you to understand what's
going on with your life so go to
ramsesolutions.com click that get
started button and we're going to help
you out wherever
you're out that's how that goes all
right let's go to Ella in Houston
umbrella what's up oh
I am trying to think of a way to pay off
my credit cards and I need to get some
repairs on my house and I was wondering
which would be better
to refinance for my mortgage company or
just go through a loan or a finance
company
um what's making you feel like in order
to do these things you've got to pull it
out through different sources of debt or
tap into your home equity
well I didn't know which way would be
better okay let's let's see if we can
talk through that a little bit how much
credit card debt are we talking about
um close to eight thousand dollars okay
how much uh for the home you said home
repairs yes I mean a lot done um I need
a new air conditioner unit okay and my
floors need redoing and I'm needing
Windows across these are really old and
they're not energy efficient okay and
they came in all through the house and
okay okay so how much are you earning
currently
or are
what's your financial situation
um monthly I'm here
you said mostly monthly is a little over
3 600 a month okay A little over 3 600 a
month how old are you
79. okay and what type of money is this
is this coming from retirement is this
coming from
retirement and pension okay and is it
just you
yes okay
who's telling you you need to do all
these aesthetic things
coach telling me I know it has to be
done I mean my insurance health
insurance has already told me I needed
to request to lose because
um it's Lincoln Eliana need a feeling
some parts of their student information
because of the week oh I I I don't get
me wrong absolutely but when I when I
think of if I look at the list let me
back out both Jade and I are gonna plead
with you
I might even beg
please don't borrow money
not at not at 79 years not ever I don't
want you to be beholden to some bank
that's going to keep you from sleeping
every night I would much rather you
figure out a way to pay for this in cash
over time
air conditioner emergency especially I
grew up in Houston I get that's brutal
roof replacement especially in a in a
community like Houston it will mold and
cause a disaster you got to get that
fixed yeah but sometimes if all I can
afford is a five thousand dollar fix
then I'm gonna have them not replace the
whole thing have them fix it so I can
save up is that is that inconvenient
yeah am I going to maybe be redoing some
work down the road yeah
but I'm gonna put my head on my pillow
every night there in that town knowing
that nobody owns me
so we're gonna recommend you not do that
how much cash do you have on hand you
have any savings or cash at all
um
in that Mission not enough
generation
thousand
yeah okay
um
where does that money go
more credit cards and food and gas okay
so you're getting you're you're pulling
about 3 600 a month to live on
um what's your you know your nest egg
how much is that
if you don't mind me asking there's not
much like I said I don't have any no
more saved up benefits too probably two
thousand no I'm talking about you said
you draw some of the money from a
pension and I thought you said you draw
some money off of retirement yeah I get
about 3 600 a month a little bit over
3600 a month and that is that is there a
nest egg that that's coming off of yeah
how much is how much is in those
retirement accounts
how much is in my retirement
my my um
my Social Security it's all like yeah
okay oh okay okay so it's Social
Security is pension gotcha all right
um and I'm guessing you I mean the
payments that you get from your pension
you can't
access that in any other way
no got it okay and then two if I don't
get my repairs
the insurance health insurance will not
what that happened with me too I I
understand how that happens what's your
mortgage payment every month Ella nine
nine hundred and ten dollars okay 910
where's the rest of that money going
what I'm trying to get at here is I want
to make it to where we're paying off
this credit card debt it's eight
thousand dollars I know that feels like
a lot but I think you can get that
knocked out pretty quickly if we get you
on a budget and if it's the house you
know 900 okay
that's working for you but what else are
you putting money towards besides that
that's taking the rest of this 3600 and
is there a way that we can start paying
off this credit card and then is there a
way that we can start looking at these
you know repairs in order of importance
little by little because AC you know if
your AC is going out it's the middle of
summer that's top of top of the list
right and then some of the other things
like painting might be you know last on
the list yeah so I think it's a matter
of getting these listed in order of
importance and finding a solution that
fits in your budget because at the end
of the day that's all you've got yeah oh
I have one more thing that I have to get
done
um my vehicle
I was told that I have to have a new
engine because they've already fixed all
they can and it's going to cost them six
to eight thousand dollars to replace the
engine for the labor and the park
so in my inspection is due
next month and it will pass inspection I
would I would get a second opinion on
that I sure would on that car okay oh I
have I've already got yeah what's the
car worth
um and so 2012 uh
Dodge Caravan I'm not sure
just make sure that the repairs aren't
worth more than the vehicle itself
yeah well they suggested that I just um
not repair it and get um get another one
because I said put more money into that
that's right but that's also easy for
them to say because they don't have to
sleep at night here's let us just
um you know how much you're struggling
with those credit card payments you know
that scary feeling that you have
yeah okay imagine taking a ten thousand
dollar roof and a seven thousand dollar
air conditioner and putting that on top
of that credit card
yeah
I get that that you're being told by
some professionals and maybe some family
members that you got to do this and you
got to do this and you got to do this
but at the end of the day here's what I
here's all I can do you got to do what
you can afford to do
and so I would pause on I would go down
to Bare Bones
I can only pay for this
um I could only pay for my rent I can
pay for the Bare Essentials on my food
and that's going to be it for a couple
of months and I'm gonna meet with a
roofer maybe two of them down there in
town and see who can take care of this
for the quickest and the least expensive
and is there a senior citizen discount
and if I pay you in cash and we're just
gonna get that roof knocked out and it's
going to be uncomfortable for three
months and that's how we're gonna live
we're gonna do the same thing with air
conditioner and if you can duct tape and
baling wire that thing together so it
gets you a little bit of cold air we're
gonna do that too maybe get a window
unit and just sit in one room or put in
your bedroom but we're not gonna borrow
money because I don't want you just
losing more and more sleep because your
body is going to wear that honey okay
[Music]
we'll see you next time
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting live from the Pod
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America is hanging out
to have a conversation about your life
and your money I am your host Jade
warshaw joined by Dr John deloney and
this hour we're going to be taking calls
about you you get to decide what it is
that we're going to talk about today are
we going to talk about getting on a
budget are we going to talk about
renting versus buying a house outright
are we going to talk about how to get
this money saved
the show is about you so give us a call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number and in the meantime
we're gonna go to Sherry in Calgary
Canada
oh sharing what's going on girl
oh nothing much I kind of had uh I hope
you guys are doing well today by the way
but um
Canadian like welcome like you just had
to get some niceness in there you're so
great
well thank you
um so I'm gonna
kind of a weird situation
like I guess more of a question for you
John all right Jade but um so I'm a part
of a family business and I came back
full time from uh University two years
ago
and I'm struggling setting up boundaries
with my dad who is the owner and has
been for the last since I was born so 25
years ago
and um I'm trying to get my life set up
like not only professionally which I
think I'm doing a pretty good job but
and I don't mean to disrespect him at
all but just like telling him that I
cannot physically work as much as he can
and um like I haven't had a day off and
I think over four months
wow I'm burning out and I don't know how
to tell him like I see I have had these
conversations where I I tell him like
Hey I can't you know I need a day to
just get the house in order and like do
laundry and he just doesn't understand
that is it just you and him
it's pretty much just me and him yeah
and I try to give him days off and he's
been able to take a vacation in the span
of time and he's he's about 60 so I just
I feel bad letting him take on all the
work all the time and also like I'm
trying my best but I just don't know
how to deal with this no it's it's
absolutely there's a reason there's
there's
um
laws about breaks a human can't work
four months in a row without a day off
that's that's just Madness and so I
think from agriculture so I have like
over 200 hours a month exactly
um so
is it okay if I'm super direct with you
we'll still be best friends yeah go
ahead all right sure so
I want you to put the family business
aside I want you to put the um
relationship with your dad off to the
side for a second
and if you called into this show and you
said hey I'm working for this supervisor
he's a nice guy
I've told him what I need I told him
that I'm running into the ground that
I've worked for four days straight I'm
working 200 hours a week running AG
I would tell you to quit the job before
the day is over because it's going to
kill you
the thing the reason you're calling is
because you know it is killing you you
can feel it
and you also have this other thing
hovering over here which is your
relationship with your dad
and so yeah the best I have ever seen it
in my whole professional career
is the way Dave and Rachel and Daniel
and Denise the kids handle it here's a
couple of the rules and I've seen it in
action and as a bystander it can be
super uncomfortable
When Rachel Cruz asks did you hear what
Dave said and I'm asking like is this a
test because that's your dad it's your
dad at the office all the kids call him
Dave
they refer to him as Dave I've seen them
in meetings get very heated and the
conversation is to Dave and to Rachel
right and then I've seen him at the
house and it's Dad
and everybody at the table life
separation yes everybody at the table
has to agree that we can talk about work
for somebody to bring up work there's
just a big no no no no no and I've seen
it it's incredible right it's here's the
deal you're not getting that from your
dad like you should
so you have to take a time you have to
take you have to get back in the
driver's seat of your own life and say
Dad I no longer work on Sundays period I
will not work yeah I'm crashing into the
ground I'm not going to answer my phone
my phone shuts off Sherry what happens
if you do that
well it's not just consequences for like
our relationship right it's like the
business in general and I've tried to
bring up maybe because we can afford it
we can hire help but he just doesn't
like seem to want to trust people
he doesn't need to because you keep
showing up
he doesn't need to hire anybody
and you show up right as the great Henry
Cloud says your dad needs to get some
problems that's so good he needs to get
nobody working on Sunday and he'll hire
somebody yeah no I totally agree with
you it's just um I've tried to do that
like um this winter I kind of tried to
set up a schedule with everybody and um
then I also started interviewing people
just kind of without his consent because
I'm also like kind of an owner operator
now well and not really because you're
not getting the salary right yeah you're
not getting paid but you want to get
paid you're working yeah no I get paid I
get paid quite a bit and I think that's
successfully negotiate
um my way up but it's just kind of um
and I do have a lot of decision making
power I do all of our marketing I I've
definitely made this place grow over the
course of two years
John and I are not arguing you're about
to keep apologizing to the company we
know your value like I just don't know
how to get him on board with me hiring
another job he's a solution he's not
going to you've tried you've tried for
months and months to reason with him to
to educate him he's not getting the
message Sherry you're so sweet
and you love him and he's your dad you
need to give this man some problems I am
not working on Sundays and I leave
Saturdays at noon that's right I will
lead the hiring if you would like me to
hire somebody but I don't work on those
days because I have to have my life
this can't be the rest of your life even
if this was the life he chose and you
grew up with a dad who worked 200 hours
a week and you didn't get to meet him
until after you got out of college he
works more he has another business but
he also runs that's right so I think if
she's just seeing me as like oh well you
only have one thing to handle so listen
listen listen listen
he doesn't get a vote into your personal
life in your business life you've gone
into partnership with him he absolutely
gets a vote and I would suggest sitting
down and saying dad here's here's my
rules I'm gonna call you by your first
name here because I'm struggling with
these these roles getting crossed I'm
I'm it's hard for me to balance them so
I'm gonna start calling you Dan at work
and I'm gonna call you Dad at home yeah
calling me dude actually I am actually
at work I'm gonna call you Dan and then
at home I'm gonna call you Dad and then
Sundays I don't work
Saturdays I'm off at noon I will walk
out and you have to be courageous and
gangster and brave and actually walk out
and it will have to be uncomfortable for
a couple of times before your dad's like
oh just hire somebody then if you're
just gonna quit on me all right cool
I'll hire somebody
and then make it happen that way I think
Sherry's a g I think she's gonna she
asked her I think she's gonna gangster
up and and put dad in his rightful place
so she can maintain her relationship a
lot yeah this is all in service of I
want to still like you as my dad okay
and I'm starting to not like you as my
dad that's how you do it John laid it
out for you this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all right all right all right all right
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw your host today joined by
Dr John deloney your other host for the
day taking calls about your life and
money you know the number triple eight
eight two five five two two five is it
all right our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly's
Nationwide network of locally owned home
service pros like Molly Maid you got
shelf Genie you've got Mr Appliance
these guys take the stress out of home
repairs maintenance and improvements
visit neighborly.com to schedule a
service today I think I need to holler
at all of those people I do too all
right today's question comes from
Charlotte in Tennessee
Oh Charlotte just cuts right to it what
is the downside to purchasing something
with zero percent interest what's the
downside
question
um
to go back to a little thing
it is a proverb and it says the borrower
is indeed slave to the lender
but so I'm gonna play Devil's Advocate
but it's there's that borrowing doesn't
cost me anything well it does cost you
you're not paying anything additional so
let's say okay let's say we have a
vehicle it's twenty thousand dollars and
you finance it right zero percent so
you're not paying you're still paying
payments you're not paying anything
additionally but you still said hey I'm
gonna pay you x amount of dollars for
the next five years for this car so
you're still adding a layer of risk to
your life you're a slave to that lender
because it's like hey I'm on the hook to
pay this money if anything should happen
in my life if I lose my job if I don't
know Mama decides she wants to stay at
home now and be a stay-at-home mom and
we go down to a one income family and
now I'm feeling the stress of that we're
still there's still this idea John that
if we can't pay cash for something we
can't afford it period if you're asking
how much a month instead of asking how
much then you're do you see what I'm
saying you're borrowing at that point so
so even though
um theoretically yeah if you are if you
were going to borrow money which I think
is a horrible idea and yeah if you a
lower interest rate is better than a
higher interest rate and a zero interest
rate is better than interest but you're
still borrowing money to that end I'd be
like hey just pay it off and the average
car loan is between five and seven years
now right they've kicked it out just for
context six years ago
was two states and three jobs for me
away that I did not know existed wow
yeah
two states and three jobs away and so to
say I'm gonna sign I'm gonna chain
myself to something even though it's not
going to be a chain and a slap in the
face it's just gonna be a chain and for
the next five to seven years I'm I'm
confident enough in our government I'm
confident enough in my boss who I don't
like I'm confident enough in the market
that I'm watching fail right in front of
whatever whatever you do yeah I'll be
okay I'll be able to make these payments
that's such a good point you're just
telling yourself and dude I live a
thousand miles from where I would have
signed that note
for God's sake
and so the idea that it's just your life
is going to be static that your kids are
not going to need braces that whatever
is going to happen and listen
I get it because I've been you listening
if you guys who are listening watching
I've been you going yeah but that
happens to other people Jade and I and
Dave and Rachel George none of us would
have a job
if everybody's plans always worked out
we would have this building wouldn't
keep us in business John I'm saying that
everybody's got as the great Mike Tyson
said everyone has a plan until you get
hit in the mouth and everybody gets hit
in the mouth and so don't set yourself
up don't chain yourself to something
hoping that your world is static seven
years from now if you can't pay for pay
for it in cash you cannot afford it you
can't afford it and that's okay that is
okay that's okay you know you make such
a good point John we always project it's
like when we project the future it's
always perfect
I'll be in this job and I'll be making
this money and the kids will be healthy
and everybody will be perfect and it's
like no day I wish that was the case we
do it worse Jade we one up we go and I'm
gonna be getting five percent raises
every year so in six years I'm gonna be
making this much and then I'll be which
is even more ridiculous then to keep the
day because it's like look if you know
you're making money go ahead and pay
that joker off that's all I'm saying
okay I think we basically drilled that
one into the ground I want you to be
free that's all I'm saying the a
borrower a slave to the lender if you
don't ask how much a month simply ask
how much and pay in cash that's even
better I've learned a story just say I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you this much
can I give you this much for that car
can I give you this much for that thing
and man that that changes the
conversation a lot I like it I like it
all right let's move on let's go to
Kelly in Philadelphia
look we were both there hey the
playground is where she spent most of
her days what's up Kelly
hey guys how are you good
um very similar to the storyline that
you were going around around uh with
getting punched in them in the face
um definitely living in that right now
oh I'm sorry what happened
so
I made an assumption about a situation
um needless to say the back story is I
um
I got debt free about five years ago
um started saving up really uh heavily
for a house that was always my dream to
be able to buy something of my own
um ended up in a relationship about
three years ago and at that time I was
still living at my parents house and we
went for it we decided that you know I
had enough money saved I was gonna put
down money on a house and we can move
into it and have our future
um you know home for for the long term
um needless to say uh that relationship
ended
um so now I have a house that's probably
at the top tier of my budget
um that I am struggling to decide what
to do with now so I love the community
I'm in I I love my neighborhood I feel
like this is the one thing that is now
consistent in my life versus all the
other changes that I'm going through
um but I'm making about two thousand
dollars more than or sorry two hundred
dollars more
um than what my expenses are per month
so I'm trying to decide if this house
that I have an extra room in would it
make sense to have a roommate and try to
you know get back to
um you know being able to pay towards
this a little bit faster than I am
currently and I'm gonna let John I'm
going to let John talk to you about what
I think is deeper than the money issue
here if but hear me when I say if you
only have two hundred dollars a margin
this house is too expensive
um having a roommate is a good idea but
I would only enter into a situation like
that when you know you can make the
payment regardless of a roommate and the
roommate is just icing on top so you
need to think about a way to get out of
this home and John's going to tell you
why yeah except I'm gonna put a caveat
on it
um okay
this is how long ago is this breakup it
sounds like it is still right there at
the top of your heart
um it
um okay so you're still living
I'm budgeting now like what does my
future look like obviously this was on
the back burner for the first few weeks
of trying to
you know yeah just breathing yeah so but
you know I'm trying to be smart about my
next steps and
yes so you worked right
um
somebody who is very important to me a
mentor of mine the guy who who trained
me on crisis response actually the guy
that gave me the phrase facts of your
friends Dr Young
he gave me some personal wisdom when I
had a personal tragedy several years ago
that was very that has proven to be wise
not only in my life but in the life of
people I've sit with when things get
sideways and that is if at all possible
do not make a giant decision for at
least six months after something wild
has happened in your life
and so
I can imagine you having memories in
this home with this boyfriend about you
you made plans in this house and I bet
you'd walked by a room and thought that
was going to be the nursery
like you've made plans in this house and
so the Temptation I completely
understand would be to run from this
thing
and if you think you can sell this house
and be done awesome
um and just and just clear your hands of
it great but also sounds like you're
connected to this place in something a
little bit different so let's do this I
want you to hang on the line we're gonna
go to a break and then we're going to
bring you back right when the break's
over we're going to talk this through
all the way I'm gonna give you a couple
of options I think that might be helpful
for you okay thank you so much you got
it hang on the line and we'll be right
back here on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
what's going on everybody you are
listening to the Ramsay show a show
about life and money and getting it all
together and making it look right
because some of y'all situation is not
looking right and you need help that's
cool we're all trying to do better give
us a call the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
we're going to try to help you John is a
mental health expert and they call me
John a money expert I got it hey you're
an expert at teaching people how to do
the right thing oh that's right that's
right and so hey at the last right for
last break we were talking to Kelly who
was out in Philadelphia and she had a
dream she bought a house she saved up a
lot of money she was she moved in with
her boyfriend her boyfriend moved in her
house and they had dreams and plans and
then they broke up and now she's looking
at the budget like the smoke is starting
to clear on the reality he's moved out
he's gone and
after all bills are covered she's got
two 100 bills left oh that's right and
she is feeling the pinch did I get that
right Kelly
that is very close to yeah okay correct
yeah so here's sitting close to him
literally and there's it sounds almost
surreal to hear somebody else just
rattle off your life right yeah and I
haven't really verbalized it so even
just hearing somebody else telling me
about it it's a little surreal for sure
so if you could if you put your house on
the market today in the area where you
live would would it sell pretty quick
yes okay
so I think that's an option to consider
and
one thing you mentioned that I think we
discount a lot in our culture is
community is I like I've got friends
I've got neighbors I've got people who
will show up at 2 am if I need them you
it sounds like you have that in your
community
I do yeah okay if people say like I
really love the area because it's got a
pool and like it's close to a Publix I
could care less if somebody says like no
I got some ride or dies in this
community that that means something to
me that means something to me so I might
reach out if I if you were my sister I
would say hey call a couple of friends
and see if you could have a roommate by
the end of the month by next month if
you could have somebody move in and just
say this is for six months while the
Smoke Clears on this thing and you may
hear me crying in my room at night
sometimes and that's okay
um do you think that would be possible
it's gonna be weird and annoying but is
that possible possible okay that's
definitely possible how do you feel if
you had a roommate it was paying you
1500 bucks or a thousand bucks or
whatever to give you a little bit of of
Gap room there how does that feel
I'm not too proud to do that
I thought you were gonna say I Ain't Too
Proud to Beg and I was about to
high-five you through the phone
um so you're not I would I would go as
far as to not even say I'm Too Proud to
do that I would say no I get to I get to
help somebody out in a in a wild rental
market and I get to sleep at night for a
season
um and then the other question you're
gonna have to ask yourself for the next
five to six months while this person's
living there is do you like having a
roommate is this a long-term thing and
Jade brought up a really important point
I'm always nervous for someone to have a
house payment that they can't afford
unless they have a renter and so it may
be I need to start looking at different
work it may be that I need to start
looking at can I take on a second job
and get this mortgage down and then
refinance it how can I change my
financial situation before I just run
off and haul off and sell this house
um what's your what's your monthly
payment on this place
um it's just over 1600. just over 1600
you couldn't even rent a place for that
out there could you no yeah that's where
I'm like in this weird yeah dilemma I
would get I would grab a roommate until
I could just because you think the fog
is clearing now it's probably going to
be a couple more months at least okay
hey what's your what's your monthly
take-home pay
uh it's 3 100. okay yeah
um what do you do for a living Kelly
are you still there just cut out
sorry I work for an insurance company
how much do you make a year
uh it's just about 68 000.
okay
are you yeah this is
this is definitely tight
um
I I mean I'm with John definitely on the
emotional side of things holding off and
just letting the Smoke Clear but I do
want you getting into a situation where
you're the one that's able to afford
this house even without a roommate
having a roommate's great like that's
you know income or whatnot but you're
not gonna feel calm until you know that
you can afford this even without the
renter do you see what I'm saying yeah
yeah I do have I do have ten thousand
dollars saved as like my emergency phone
some relief on that end but I definitely
feel like I need to start making a
decision so that yeah because your
emergency fund is not mine yeah because
your emergency fund is not there to
float you you know month to month it's
there for exactly you know and you get
that so so maybe get a roommate for six
months or a year and sock that money
away
um just just keep that cash for if
you're gonna end up transitioning out or
transitioning moving whatever comes up
um and then maybe over the next two or
three months I think you'll find some
peace there and
um
I think some clarity emerges if you can
just hold on during this storm here but
yeah 200 bucks extra month man that's
that's any number of things cost more
than 200 but I'm trying to think of the
electrical issue I've got that's
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars so
um yeah that's really really tight
thanks for the call Kelly that's that's
a tough situation but I think that
you've got the tools to navigate that
from here on out uh John let's take
another call let's let's talk to
Christopher oh he's from your neck of
the woods Fort Worth he's from the right
side eight one seven what's up
Christopher
oh what's going on I'm just trying to
get my wife on the same page and you
know figure out that our finances are
are as bad as I'm thinking they are
because I'm always going to sleep over
it basically here we're going paycheck
to paycheck my wife's having to you know
do the little pay advances through work
to get to the next week so stuff gets
paid
yeah
then we've got you know small credit
card debts or the rent to owns and
so go ahead John say what what turn the
light on for you
I just I mean just even though that
we're both making I mean significantly
you know we're making around you know 70
80 000 a year so we're bringing home
four or five thousand dollars a month
but yeah but you're renting to own bro
you're you're either propping up a
lifestyle that's not real or you are
baroque
I mean yeah
I mean like Rent to Own Furniture rent
to own
but you appliances why are you guys why
do you guys keep choosing that
um my screen I'm just going to tell you
what my screen says my screen says how
do I get my wife
to take our finances seriously
but yeah and that's the biggest thing
right there because everything that I've
suggested as far as ways that we can cut
around the budget something always gets
shot down this is not about cutting
around the budget this is about changing
your entire life you're talking to
somebody in Jade who slept on an air
mattress for years you're talking about
me who for our 20th anniversary my wife
said hey we've had a headboard that you
bought off Craigslist and spray painted
could we get a real bed 20 years and
listen brother Dave Ramsey pays us real
real well
so like Rent to Own Furniture I can't it
can't even wrap my head around how
insane that is insanity that that what
that tells me is you guys are that my
what my dad used to say trying to keep
up with the Joneses if you're renting to
Own Furniture because you want you feel
like you should have a certain look and
a certain this you guys need to kiss
that goodbye and and get real with what
you earn what that looks like monthly
and the lifestyle that you can actually
afford and as it relates to your wife
you know I I'll be honest
marriage it's a two-way street you know
both folks are on it so it's not like
unless she went to the rental rent to
own place without you unless she said
and decided on her own I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do that it's both of you guys
you're if she's doing it you're allowing
it so it's both of you guys contributing
to this mess and it's going to take both
of you guys to get on the same page and
to really sit down and say are we going
to be adults or are we going to be kids
almost every time Chris a guy calls me
with this they're some sort of schemer
they've had some sort of plan and then I
got another plan and then then five
years or ten years into the relationship
it's like oh I got this other plan to
get this job I'm gonna flip houses is
that you
no no okay we're basically it's you know
we were making you know pretty much
minimum wage jobs barely making it and
then as we were I thought I guess almost
thought we were making more so we wound
up I guess getting into the Trap of spin
yeah y'all started spinning you just
quit saying no so listen I want you to
take your wife out for breakfast and say
the following honey I'm scared to death
about our money would you make a budget
with me would you help me be intentional
about our money so that we can change
our family tree hang on the line we're
going to send you Financial Peace
University I want you all to watch those
classes together and change your life
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what's going on everybody you are
listening to the Ramsay show I'm your
host Jade warshaw joined by John deloney
give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and we will do our best to answer your
question or put you on the right track
uh let's take a call let's go to Cheney
in Waco Texas what's going on Cheney
yeah hey how are you
I'm doing good um so I'm just to it my
husband
my husband on baby steps four five and
six and we have five kids so we're
trying to figure out the 529 situation
um I'm getting nervous oh don't be
nervous
um so our we had our kids are seven five
three two and one oh girl and our
youngest yeah
right now very good they're not too loud
um but uh our youngest two have college
taken care of we adopted them so um
that's part of their Adoption Subsidy
okay but um our oldest three we don't
have anything set up for them yet okay
we have about three to four hundred
dollars a month
um to put towards that that's great
question is should we have three
separate 529s
um or just one big one should we do five
for all of them just in case or that's
such a good question
um with 529s of course I always you know
would suggest that you get with a Ramsay
trusted uh professional on that that can
help you with the investment side of it
um because they're going to help you
decide how to divvy up that money
whether you should focus on you know one
kid first that being the oldest or you
know they're gonna help you sort through
that that being said and they're going
to help you select the right one because
they're State specific right and you can
choose you don't have to necessarily
choose the state that you live in you
can choose another State's 529 that
might have better options for you so
definitely work with a Ramsay trusted
professional on that but as far as the
idea of do you need just one account or
open one for all of them
um off the top of my head I would I
would probably open one for all of them
for a couple of reasons
um
one being like the beneficiary situation
I think that it's simpler because once
that money is in there it's designated
for that child now some of them
depending on the state you can use them
for different siblings on down the line
but um just to keep it clean I'd
probably do separate 529s for each of
them John do you have anything to add to
that yeah there's also some tax
advantages and so depending on what
states you live in they may allow X
number thousands of dollar deduction
based on
a 529 plan and if you have three kids in
one plan you're gonna get a single
deduction if you have three plans you
get to deduct that each time Ah that's a
very good point so yeah I I would just
for cleanliness and then the final thing
in and you know I'm gonna have to go all
dark and sad here but if something were
to happen to you and your husband and
you have these existing plans and
there's just one lump sum
you're gonna have to expect your
custodian to properly delineate this and
make decisions on this versus this and
we want to support this kid who was the
first kid in college and they got into
Stanford and then the other kid you see
what I'm saying it just gets messy if
you have them delineated out there's no
confusion there if me as an executor if
I show up to take care of your kids and
your absence I'm able to go okay here's
account for this kid here's account for
this kid here's to come for this kid and
that's I just it like Jane said I mean
Jade said it just makes it clean and I
think I think that makes it simple
what do you think thank you guys so much
yeah
that sounds mowing over this
about a month so yeah and by the way
there can be a analysis by a paralysis
by analysis
just open them up and get rolling you're
good yeah really good at that paralysis
awesome thanks for the call Chaney we
appreciate you
very very cool that's good stuff John um
things to think about in baby step five
baby step five is funding kids college
and we do suggest you know 529 plans um
esa's can work and you know in the baby
steps we don't say a specific amount you
know a lot of times we'll say hey save
three to six months or invest fifteen
percent of your income but when it comes
to kids college we're pretty uh open
about what you decide to do or decide
what you don't want to put into that you
might be the type that's like hey my
kids are going to get a job and get
scholarships and they're going to work
through school and we're only gonna you
know fund this little bit so it's up to
you decide what you want to do with that
but I think that's important and here's
here's the key you have to be honest and
open with your kid probably when they're
a freshman in high school that's right
there's going to be fifty thousand
dollars in this account you can go to
Community College locally for free and
then you can go to any state college you
want to in the United States for that 50
000 for the back half or you can go to
the state school and use 25 of it and
then 25 of it for grad school whatever
but there's gonna be 50 in that account
oh there's gonna be 10 in that account
period or there's gonna be two hundred
thousand dollars in this like whatever
yes but it's a parent's job even when it
feels shameful when it even when it
feels embarrassing to sit down with your
kid really early in the process oh yeah
here is the situation when it comes to
college I think that is the
that is the determining factor in all of
this because so many kids they get you
know they turn 18 and it's like they've
got this idea in their mind of where
they want to go right and they they're
the ones that start talking about it
first and then the parents are like oh
you know she says she wants to go to
Emory that's expensive and then instead
of them ex because they never mentioned
payment before now you turn to student
loans and that's how you go start going
down that crazy train of student loans
so having that conversation look John my
parents said to all of us there's four
of us
um I have two brothers and a sister and
my parents were like y'all better be
really smart or really great athletes
because y'all ain't getting any money
but hey they told you on the front end
they told us on the front end if you
want to know what I did I played like
three different sports and I tried to
figure out which one I can master I got
a volleyball scholarship and I was like
I gotta turn it I gotta figure out how
to do math so I can get an academic
scholarship and I did and um you know it
would have been great to be one of those
people that's got a college fund and
money set up for you but the key here is
everybody's not going to be in that
situation and even if you do have a
college fund if it's only ten thousand
dollars so what you're saying is really
the solution here it's just have these
conversations with your kids let them
know what the expectation is let them
know what you can and cannot do and it's
as simple as that I love that I love it
cool cool you think we can take another
call let's go for it do it real quick
come on Mr o'clock brother what's up
thanks for taking my call I'm struggling
if I should sell my rental property in
Orange County and uh I've owned it for
44 years uh I recently wound up with
some noisy neighbors upstairs it's a get
a little more difficult to rent out and
uh it's getting tougher to find uh good
tenants
I'm 75.
is this your only is it is it completely
paid for yes right oh yes do you have
any other debt
no no debts at all so if you sold this
it would just be because I'm tired of
fooling with it it's getting harder and
harder to rent maybe I can do something
better pretty much it yeah yeah I mean
with the profit I'm just gonna probably
put it in t bills or something like that
you know dude you are I can hear it in
your voice
and this is a good thing you're done
being a landlord yeah you've got 20
years left to ride off into the sunset
without dealing with idiots messing up
the plumbing or whatever yeah it's time
and be honest Bill Neil you got you got
money
you got some money laying around okay
yeah I could hear it in your voice
treat it like it'll oh I was gonna say I
was gonna say Something's Gonna Get me
canceled
um I would like because that's been a
part of your life you almost have a
relationship with this place right yeah
that's right then that's the problem
yeah it is the problem but also it's
it's just an apartment so I would not
sell it I would sell it tomorrow and I
would take that cash yes and I'd put it
in some sort of retirement vehicle all
right you know what I do I'd actually
spend some of it too brother go have
some fun
I love that sounds good thank you and
then next month when uh
you have no nothing to go fix or no
repair man to call you can just smile
real big and then check your account
balance and and and and and and smile
even bigger that's right I love it what
you think Neil
sounds like a plan sounds like a plan
congratulations man I love calls like
that John Neil that's the business Neil
set up a 44 years man I asked him same
property look I oh I was treading
lightly because I'm like after 44 years
you better dab gum well on this house
thank goodness he did I could tell that
he did but um I love those I love those
kind of calls where it's like hey I
basically got wealth sitting right here
what can I do with it there's no bat
there's no wrong answer but you're right
he was just tired of fooling with the
renting game well and it's okay
listen America listen to me carefully
it's okay to change your mind
you can not want anything to do with
real estate and then be all in on real
estate and then I don't want to be a
landlord anymore you get to do that
because that because America change your
mind it's not a sign of weakness it's a
sign of strength good for you I love
that all right guys that does it for
today's show we'll see you next time
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions and broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I am your host Jade warshaw
conveniently joined by co-host Dr John
deloney and we are taking calls about
your life your money we are here all
afternoon you guys can call in the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five so if you are at home
and you got the YouTube on and you're
vacuuming you can call if you're
listening first out you know call us in
if you're like man I've always listened
to that show but I don't know if they'll
take my call call you never know you
might get through
um if you're listening on podcast write
down the number and then you know next
time you know when it's time give us a
call we want to chat about the things
that are important to you we want to
help you sort out your life and your
money and by the way if you are a person
that's listening thank you for listening
you guys are what keep us you keep us
running as the Doobie Brothers said and
we are so grateful for you listening
whether it's on the podcast app Spotify
Apple wherever you listen thank you and
do us one more do a favor and share the
show if you can share it with a buddy of
yours you can text them your favorite
episode but when you do that it's good
for all of us it makes this show become
more apparent in people's feed you know
what I'm saying it pops pumps it up in
the algorithm so they see it and more
people can get this news of Hope and
freedom and we want that so go ahead and
share it while you're there go ahead and
like it subscribe it that would be very
very good because you know John we don't
we're not out here spending these uh
these advertising dollars like like some
of these folks are and uh you guys y'all
did it y'all are the ones that shared it
so thank you for that all right let's go
to the phone lines I think I'm ready to
do that we've got Val from Edmonton
Canada oh Lord what's going on in
Edmonton Val
oh my gosh I'm so excited I'm so nervous
I'm so glad you guys took my calls I
appreciate it
Val you were okay hey Val you are the
second Canadian to call to start the
show with such kindness and positivity
thank you for injecting joy into this
wild world we live in
the biggest lesson I've learned is
unfortunately
um well fortunately I've been listening
to this Dave Ramsey Show for a very long
time and at the beginning I didn't
really you know I listened to it because
I applied that I'm the type of person
that will not sleep overnight because I
owe money or I'm in debt and
unfortunately my ex-husband didn't feel
that way but the good news is when I
start listening to Dave Ramsey there
were so many uh red flags saying we're
not doing that we're not doing that I am
but he's not but we're not then
virtually unfortunately
um almost ended up on the street because
of his gambling and um but when I tried
to implement all of these things it was
very appealing for me even though very
painful
um that I realized we're not on the same
page at all and nor were we gonna be and
he would just you know keep gambling
keep you know almost lost my mind and
almost lost my home and so on and so
forth so if nothing else
please everybody that's listening
um it's painful but you have to do it
because at the end of the day it's going
to happen anyways so at least you're
going to be prepared
um the other thing I want to ask I'm 68
years old and I've taken menial jobs
which I never think through menial jobs
but not what I usually do in my life
I've always worked with non-profit for
low-income seniors or you know kids or
whatever and I'm just wondering at the
stage of the game that I have a very
hard time finding a job I have to take
cleaning jobs or retail job things that
are a little bit harder for me but I
guess the question I guess I really want
to know how do I get to live comfortably
I know I've downsized everything
apartment I can't find apartments too
expensive and you know jobs are very you
know they don't want to hire you because
your job so I guess there are times
where I think well how do I go about
that like so right now you're feeling so
the word I heard was how do I live
comfortably so right now it feels like
you're living paycheck to paycheck yeah
feels like you don't have money to do
the things that you want to do and maybe
even some of the things that you need to
do is that what I'm hearing
yes and I think the biggest thing that
I'm questioning is how did I get here so
quickly when I've worked hard all my
life two jobs I worked 80 hours a week
to pay off Revenue Canada because I got
done with that well my guess is my guess
is you know sometimes we find ourselves
in situations and it's like man how did
I get here it may have been some choices
that were made that got you there
whether by you directly or for the by
the people that you know affect your
life it sounds like your husband has
played a major part in the state of your
finances at this point so right now can
I get just a quick picture of what
things look like tell me what your
um what you're bringing home every month
after taxes and then I kind of want to
get a picture of what if there's debt if
there's savings I kind of want to get a
quick picture of your financial snapshot
so what do you take home every month
after taxes
about three thousand a month okay and I
have my my pensions
in addition to
uh that's yeah that's about a thousand a
month so okay so now we're to about 4
200 a month
yeah okay anything else that you want to
add to that monthly income
no that's it okay great and the problem
I'm struggling with is on doing clean
and it's it's taken a toll on me right I
don't know how much longer I can do this
and I'm getting stressed out about it
because if I uh don't do this job and
been trying to find other jobs uh and
then I'm down to a thousand a month and
that's just not enough to live on right
that's right
um what's your debt situation
great uh what's your living situation
are you home owner or are you renter
no um renting actually moved in with my
son because uh the rents were getting
too high in the power I just couldn't
manage it uh because at the time I
couldn't find a job and now I've
actually found a job but still I can't
if I'm falling deep agencies uh areas
that's why I downsize a year ago I was
renting from a friend and that become a
little
um a little dicey there and too much
money and my son split up with his wife
so
um I decided to move in with him and
help him is there a timeline on that is
there a timeline with your son no there
isn't and that was the other question
I've been there a year now
okay
okay are you still there by the way
oh yeah okay so you've been with your
son for a year
um I my guess is there is going to be an
end date at some point to this and you
guys might want to start talking about
this but the key is you know you've got
to start getting your savings you have
three to six months of savings and then
if so are you investing any money
because I where I'm hung up here Val is
you don't have any debt you have an
income
but yet and still you're still living
paycheck to paycheck so part of my
question is where is all this money
going towards every single month at this
point in the game if you have no debt
The Next Step would be to save three to
six months of expenses and after that
you gotta start investing some money you
got to start getting some money set
aside for the future because you're
right a thousand dollars is not gonna
cut it and I can't help you with work
the work in Edmonton hang on the line
we're going to send you um Ken Coleman's
book proximity principle that will help
you get some ideas on how you can find
some work there it is there but it can
be tough to find it
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
action guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody you are
listening to the Ramsay show and thank
you for listening I'm your host Jade
warshaw joined by John deloney give us a
call and you can be live on air airing
all of your Grievances and money dirty
laundry I'm just kidding but do give us
a call we'd be happy to talk through
anything with you the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you want to call in uh John you know
this is one of my favorite Parts
sometimes about this show is these
articles that come through sometimes
it's articles that we ourselves found
and thought were kind of interesting or
sometimes it's just something that's on
the desk or like guys you need to look
at this uh this one came through it says
why a spending plan is better than a
budget can you give us some some light
on this what are we talking about here
yes I golly dude all right here's my
thoughts on this
okay listen here's a why a spinning plan
is better than a budget says a financial
psychologist
here's what the financial psychologist
says which by the way not a thing but
we'll go from there Financial psychology
is about the humanness of money how
people think feel behave about their
money and their relationships with money
in the past present and future
wait are you saying this is not a real
field
I can tell you I've been in and around
the field of mental health my entire
life and I've never heard the phrase
Financial psychology or a financial
psychologist okay
okay but I do like David said for years
that money is 80 psychology and 20
knowledge right 80 Behavior you gotta
know what you're thinking and doing
so
who you are contributes to what your
money is doing and where your money's
going certain forms of social
conditioning is so stupid certain forms
of social conditioning such as budgeting
also come into play let me make a very
clear statement
budgeting is not social conditioning go
off John it's not
psychologically budgets sound
restrictive here's what's happened over
the last 40 or 50 years there's been a
clever contest in my field my mental
health field of people you don't just
have anxiety you have
high functioning anxiety that's not a
thing not a thing it's not any DSM it's
not it doesn't exist oh so you're saying
folks are making up things they are
making here's why here's why to give
somebody a label for why they feel the
way they do to like diagnostic I've
gotta I've got to provide a label for
every feeling that exists in the world I
gotta label you and I don't want you to
feel uncomfortable
and so psychologically budget sounds
restrictive is what the article says a
spending plan sounds a lot better and
they give more freedom and flexibility
they actually don't so here's the here's
the catch here math still applies
whether you have a spending plan or a
budget how much money do you make how
much money do you have versus how much
do you spend and you can get all play
all kinds of semantic gymnastics a
budget is about what you spent a
spending a plan is about what you're
about to spend
what are you doing to the hurting person
sitting in front of you as you're
playing these Dungeons and Dragons games
with them with your vocabulary and
they're hurting what they need to be
told is this
you can take control of your money and
here's how much you make
and here's how much you spend who do you
want to be who do you want to become
what's the life you want to lead and how
can we get there
I will promise you
the the most shameful thing I've
experienced since leaving higher ed and
coming to work here is how my lofty
language
and my theoretical propositions and the
way I communicated was wholly unhelpful
to a single mom of three kids just
trying to figure out what can I do next
to a truck driver who's got two boys and
he just wants to be a little bit better
dad and his dad left him and he doesn't
know what to do and I'm here thinking
saying well you know
have you thought about the correct
attachment disorder bro how can I help
my kid right and so the reason this gets
it sets me off
is a budget should be restrictive and a
budget frees up everything and when you
part the way Dave uses budgets the way
Ramsey Solutions uses budgets is we are
always talking about a plan into the
future yeah and so saying that's not
that you can't just play well I guess
our whole culture does that now you
can't just say well that doesn't mean
that anymore it means this now and I'm
gonna go off to this word and I'm gonna
create a new a whole new branch of uh
psychology called Financial psychology
here's what I want everybody I want
everybody to stop with the gymnastics
and help hurting people yeah and if
you're sitting down and someone says hey
I've tried to be on a budget my dad beat
me up with a budget you say okay cool
we're not going to call it a budget
we'll call it a spending plan I'm
actually okay with that it's fine that's
fine it's semantics but to say they're
two different things and this doesn't
work and this is social conditioning
it's not it's math it's math
it's math I I agree John I'm here for
the problem I'm heartbroken man because
these are there's hurting people and
people who have gone to college for a
long long time in order to help other
people have gotten so sophisticated and
so excited about their new words and the
way they explain things and so reluctant
to have people feel uncomfortable in
front of them
that we're not helping anybody anymore
that's so good we're not helping anybody
here's the truth here's the truth and
I'm I'm backing out of this financial
psychology but whatever
more people right now than ever before
in human history are under the care of a
mental health professional more people a
licensed mental health professional more
people than ever before are under are
taking medication for psychological
issues right now yep and the trend line
is a rocket ship directly up to the moon
and Beyond
and so as a mental health Guy this is my
world these are my friends these are my
community these are who I talk to on a
regular basis this is my academic
training I have to be willing to step
back and say what we're doing is not
working
throwing this at these problems coming
up with new things that make people feel
ah I didn't want to feel restrictive or
telling somebody you've been socially
conditioned to budget you need to have a
spending put we are teaching people to
avoid reality
and an avoidance of reality at its core
makes people insane wow that's the
definition it's a lack of connectivity
to reality so I'm done talking about it
if it makes you feel better to say
spending plan knock your lights out if
it makes you feel better to say budget
at this company at Ramsey Solutions it
means it's we use these interchangeably
this is a budget is how much money do
you make how much money have you spent
and who do you want to become in the
future what's the world you want to
build that's how we've used budget for
30 years and Beyond that's right and to
my friends who are in the mental health
profession stop
stop
all of our sophisticated mumbo jumbo all
of our creating Diagnostics just so we
can get an article on some blog
somewhere
we're taking people further and further
and further away from reality and
sometimes reality is uncomfortable
sometimes reality hurts sometimes
reality is a you gotta see that you're
not safe
and coming up with these nonsensical
well you know it's not helping look
around everybody it's not working it's
not working
that's all that's all I got to say about
that sorry I would if it was socially
acceptable John in this moment I would
stand up and give you a standing
elevation but I I'm just tired of
hurting people man it's so true and yeah
I think it's just creating more and more
confusion around a topic where there's
already confusion you know or I can't
tell you how many calls and DMS and
emails that come through with I I'm just
struggling to but I just want to make a
plan for my money any plan for my money
and this just clouds all of it and makes
it even more complicated so guys it's
simple get on a plan for your money
that's all a budget is I don't care what
you call it it's deciding ahead of the
month before the month begins how you're
going to spend the money it's your hard
income you're deciding how you're gonna
spend it and some of that decision is
going to go to needs and things that
must get done and responsible tasks and
some of that money is going to go to fun
stuff and the things that you want to do
that's all it is and we got a great
budget here it's called every dollar if
you're interested in that uh it's the
best budgeting tool out there
um it's helped so many people it's the
tool that Sam and I use to help pay off
our debt and it can help you too so if
you're interested in that you can go to
their site and actually use promo code
Jade and you'll get some money off their
15 off so that's the solution budget is
the word that's the buzzword and that's
what we're going to call it here on the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
what's going on you're listening to the
Ramsay show give us a call we'll talk
about your life your money the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and without further Ado we've got
Jonathan in Charleston South Carolina
come on and raise up what's up
hey how are y'all doing good how are you
I'm doing fantastic
um I got a quick question for you so I'm
a musician
my only debt is my house and my truck
uh-huh I got some money saved up
and I would I love my job I'm rich in
spirit but it doesn't really pay like I
would like it to so I'm I'm starting to
think if I could get some sort of
passive income I have friends I do
Airbnb thing I know y'all are all about
that all the time
but uh they're suggesting I do that
they're fellow musicians and I just I'm
just trying to think a way to make my
money grow I have a good chunk saved up
for me what I think is a good chunk and
uh yeah I'm just trying to make it so I
can make a little bit more and maybe not
have to play 30 gigs a week
um
well you're a musician don't you want to
play the gigs
I mean the whole you want to do the work
right on the musician side it'd be one
thing if you're like hey I don't want to
wait tables as much I want to do more
music but if you've got 30 gigs a week
that's excellent
well it's it's more I I say 30. I teach
drum lessons and I also I probably play
like five six gigs a week which is
pretty good yeah
um I don't want to play much more than
that just because it is a lot of work
you got to think of time going into
preparation well I know I I used I I got
you I used to be a musician myself
um so I understand you on that tip
um what I'm curious about is you said
you've got a good amount of money saved
and you said you've got your house and
your truck
um can we talk about that for a moment
of course okay so I like the idea that
you're wanting to get more money coming
in
um passive
I will say is kind of a buzzword right
now and it's not real so we'll talk
about that Airbnb I like the idea of you
getting more income in because I just
love when people make good money but I
don't think that Airbnb is your route so
let's talk about what you got going on
so you've got the truck how much do you
owe on that truck
um about nine grand okay uh and then you
buy out is nine grand I have it for zero
enters and you gotta oh so it's a lease
notice I bought it and basically the
it's a long story I don't know if you
want to get into it but the dealership
messed up and they had to they decided
to make it right so they sold me a new
version of the truck I wanted with zero
interest okay and so it takes you 9k and
you you owe it you own it free and clear
yes okay cool and then you said you had
some money saved up somewhere how much
do you have saved
I got about 80 grand saved up whoa mama
that's great
um so this 80 grand that's cash cash
money right
Cash Money okay so what's keeping us
from paying off this truck today and
please don't tell me because it's zero
interest
yeah because zero interest why would I
pay it I know that I know I know I know
you could say kind of because you're a
musician and at any moment covet comes
back and you know you have no gigs and
you can't play and all my buddies who
are touring musicians oh they couldn't
breathe and you have eighty thousand
dollars just sitting there you're not
paying this thing off were you not a
musician during covid Jonathan because I
don't know about you but I was crying my
eyes out every night
and I was in good financial position
all right bring it
but he's gonna convince us
okay now I'm not gonna come in don't try
it don't try it hey before the day is
over this truck has paid off go ahead
you're gonna you didn't win anything and
the car dealership is not your friend
they didn't hook you up they screwed up
and they made it right good on them but
they're not your friend this isn't like
a great situation for you it's better
than a than just going to take a 15 loan
if I pay it off monthly or pay it off
now either way it's nine grand because
tomorrow you sleep and and tomorrow when
you're going to Costco and you're
lifting your your 40 pound jar of peanut
butter in the back of your truck you
accidentally slam your finger and all of
a sudden you can't play play guitar or
play piano or whatever it is that you
play and you're like crap I can't do my
gigs anymore that's why or you just say
hey I'm not I'm only gonna go down to
four gigs a week because I'm tired and
that 500 bucks I was gonna make on that
one
that's my truck payment I'm not paying
it no more or you're a singer and for
some unknown reason you lose your voice
and you got to cancel your get like as a
musician but I'm telling you man this
thing is precarious anything can happen
at any moment and now more than ever is
when you need that security no payments
all right that's what you need no I mean
it's not like you have a lot of debt
sitting here Jonathan I mean it's nine
thousand dollars that we're talking
about we can clear it clear thousand in
the bank man but I do want I'm just
thinking okay it's sitting in high
yielding savings John Jonathan Jonathan
Jonathan look look okay look look you
can do what you want to do you can do
what you want to do if you're asking me
which I think that you did call into the
show I think but that you really need to
just gone ahead look you're still gonna
have seventy one thousand dollars left
let me do it this way if you and three
Buddies go in and all get a uh Airbnb
right you all pitch in You all take a
huge loan out and y'all all pitch in and
this thing makes a couple of thousand
bucks a week and you put a thousand
bucks to into it and you all take some
cat a cash draw out how much is your
truck payment a month
is about three hundred dollars
there's your draw
so you're looking for passive income a
way to make three or four hundred more
dollars and then over time they're gonna
pay for Equity never works out that way
uh that's not true it does occasionally
but on the on the average it is not
you'd be doing better to take that truck
payment
s your passive income right there
brother
with no risk with no risk not one of
your buddies going off and being like
hey I quit by the way I'm not doing this
anymore or another buddy be like hey my
mom wants to move into the house he
doesn't even have to put it in a high
yield savings he can invest it he's got
he'll have three like after he pays off
this debt he'll have his three to six
months he can start investing into a
Roth IRA you can start investing that
money and actually making some Bank on
that over time your friends look at you
like a savings account because you have
eighty thousand dollars in cash
musicians
how much you have left on your house
150. oh my gosh dude let's go listen bro
let's go you are 24 months to uh to
owing nobody anything
I mean I make 35 to 40 a year
and this is my first year making that
much since Co since Kobe look what John
what John is pointing to is the idea
that if you walk down these steps you're
paying off this truck today that leaves
you with 71 000 which is more than what
we would say to have saved up in cash
right we say three to six months of
expenses so technically you could
whatever the cutoff point maybe it's 25
000 maybe it's 30 000 that you cut this
off and you take the other 35 that's
left you could technically put it
towards your house if you're not on baby
step you know you don't have any kids
you don't have to stay for college you
do you see what he's saying we want you
to invest 15 of your income and once you
pay off the car you're going to have
plenty left you're getting 300 back
every month and then from there you can
start paying off your house is what he's
saying and then in 24 months if you if
you work bananas and you you run the
gigs and you drive in the morning and
you deliver lunch and is it gonna suck
yes it is in 24 months bro you have no
house payment
then you can do what you'll want to do
yeah you should like and here's the
thing what every one of the internet
internet Bros Instagram Bros are trying
to do is trying to get you to focus on
bro if you get no percent down then you
get six percent over here you're making
the six percent you can put that and
don't have avocado toast and you'll be a
billionaire here's what we're trying to
do is give you your life back
yeah have peace man we could sleep at
night and you can don't have to take
gigs with crappy bands because you have
to have that money make me a product no
that hit me so you don't have to play
the wedding you can you don't you can
play the cool punk band gigs like you
should be doing because they're great
music man you don't have to play the
because I don't owe anybody anything and
then here's the crazy part about not
owing anybody anything
you start playing music that you really
want to play and that you're really good
at and then all of a sudden something
hits because your whole heart is in it
you're not just doing it to get to the
next thing and get to the next thing and
get to the next thing that's right this
is what happens with art man I don't
know how or why it's just how it works
man this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
you are listening to the Ramsay show a
show about life and money and mental
health in financing not financing but
getting your finances in order and
getting the right career and getting on
budget and getting on track give us a
call the number is Triple A
825-5225 scripture and quote of the day
man I love this one I can do all things
through Christ who gives me strength
that's what I'm talking about
Philippians 4 13 can never go wrong with
that one or
y'all y'all are getting me with these
quotes why do I have to get the Harriet
Tubman one it says every great dream
begins with a dreamer always remember
you have within you the strength the
patience and the passion to reach for
the stars and change the world love it
so so so so good
what's the matter with you guys
I don't know what's wrong with such just
an inspirational quote it has nothing to
do with this person I just found
something there we go whatever I hope
you sleep tonight Allison y'all give me
phone lines after that I got John help
me out hey we're gonna go to David in
Washington what's up David
hi good afternoon how are you guys doing
we're doing good we're getting there the
show producers struggling but we're
doing all right
how are you doing
all right good I appreciate you guys
taking my call today
so what's welcome how can we use uh my
fiancee yeah um my fiance are gonna be
getting married
um in early October of this year cool um
and basically my question is uh I bought
a house in um right before covet I
actually got lucky it was February 20 20
uh February uh 20th 2020. well done man
that's awesome yeah right before kind of
the uh the World Turns Upside Down um
but luckily um uh the the markets were
kind of getting spooked in China and uh
so I was able to lock in on kind of a
low interest rate
um it's an end unit townhouse my first
house
um and I guess my question is
um advice uh should you know I'm
thinking about potentially selling
um but obviously if I sell uh since I
can pay off my other debt I have a car
loan
um of about 14 500 and a small personal
loan um just that we took out to kind of
cover some of the spenses for the
wedding savings but not the personal
loan it's uh six thousand six thousand
dollars um my parents our parents
luckily are helping out with with a good
deal of it uh which is which is nice
um but you know I would say all in all
total debt um other than the mortgage of
course would be uh right around twenty
five thousand dollars
um for everything
um but you know how much are you okay
savings I can I can knock out what's
your portion of the wedding that you're
paying for
uh we're covering about about uh fifty
five hundred fifty five hundred and you
feel like you've got that covered or are
you still needing a plan for that as
well yeah no it's already paid for yeah
that's all paid for oh okay uh
everything's already arranged um you
know we talked about the Lander
honeymoon until later uh when I get my
bonus in March uh so that's no no big
deal there
um someone brought this up David someone
brought this up did she did she tell you
she don't want to live here are you
starting to feel nervous about owing 25
Grand and getting married
oh sorry something brought this up does
she tell you she doesn't really want to
live in this house
um no no no no no she definitely we're
gonna live here uh she has combined
income here all right yeah you're good
I'll get to it here so the deal is her
mother
um you know the first uh generation
immigrant um uh migrated here from El
Salvador and uh her her mom and her
sister are um our uh uh currently
renting an apartment but they're having
a hard time so if I if I were to
potentially sell
um the idea would be to pay off any debt
I have and then potentially
um you know I'm looking in the area I'm
in the Market's pretty it's kind of
expensive but if I were to upgrade a
little bit um we would have basically
three incomes
um you know to contribute to the to the
mortgage um which I think so you're
saying to get a home to house you mom
and sister am I understanding that right
correct correct just temporarily until
her sister uh is getting situated right
now so she's um she might you know move
out but just for temporarily to help her
save as well correct I would strongly
recommend I'm all about helping out
family if you've got to help out family
you gotta help out family I would not
buy a house
based on three incomes
the most I would go is say okay what's
our combined take-home income between me
and my about to be wife and that's got
to be the basis because mom might get
sick mom might get hurt you're starting
to add so many variables and in that
market DC is expensive man correct
um correct I do love your heart that you
want to help out your your wife's family
totally get that
um
sounds like you have a gold mine there
with that with that
with the place you live in right now is
that fair
and I say Goldmine it sounds like you
bought the house for about half of what
it would sell for right now and probably
locked in a decent interest rate yeah
it's uh I bought it for two uh 220
including all the closing costs back in
2020 now it's going for you know I just
got an appraised just for the heck of it
uh for 325. what's the interest rate
uh three three and a half
dude a 30-year fix it'd be tough for me
to walk away on that and can I can I be
the bad guy in in for just a moment too
yeah I man it gave me a pit in my
stomach a little bit when I thought
about you starting off your brand new
brand spanking new marriage
in a house that you bought
for your mother-in-law and sister-in-law
with you all in the same house that just
feels like a recipe for
man it's just heavy to me I'm like
that's a lot of
yeah influence you know what I'm saying
like I mean it's just hard to establish
whose home this is yeah and who you're
going to be in your marriage that's
right yeah um
the first year of marriage is so
different I mean it's different for
everybody but there's it's full of
challenges good and bad and
you're just trying to figure out who
you're going to be and to have that many
voices Under One Roof not to say that
they're just going to be speaking into
your marriage all the time but it's just
they're you're in the same household so
I
I don't I gotta be honest I don't like
that idea I think that there might be a
better way that you could help them out
but I also want to say your first UH
responsibilities to your wife and to
setting up that situation in that
Foundation correctly and then you can
start looking outward
and I feel like you've got a great heart
and you're trying to look outward right
now but it's like wait first for first
things first and so that would be my
take on it
um I you know all like I'm thinking
about my own situation I'm like if Sam
if Sam warshaw came and was like Hey
we're getting married oh and by the way
I'm gonna sell my house so that your
sister and your mom can move I would be
like oh I don't like is there something
else that we can do is there a better
way is your wife interested in helping
them out are you just trying to be super
husband
um well that's the thing so she's
helping her now so she's helped she's
paying she's helping her pay her rent
now okay so so we're
incomes getting her now
you know it's a club thing like when you
marry Latina you're basically a married
or a mother too
there's some different definite cultural
things absolutely
hey you're cutting you're cutting out
real bad on this problem what I think
let me while you're cutting out and
while you're finding service here's
here's the plan I want to give you I
want you to
um not sell the house I think that the
debt that you have I think that you can
sweep that up with the income that you
have coming in I don't want your your
fiance contributing to that at all right
now right now it's your debt you're not
married yet so start contributing to
that start knocking that out as quickly
as possible then when you guys get
married you can come in together and
start knocking this out it's 25 000 it's
going to be gone lickety-split I didn't
ask you your income yet um
but it doesn't matter 25 000 you guys
are going to clean that up in two
seconds right so that's thing one of
course I want you to have a thousand
dollars set aside before you start
tackling that debt but then once that
debt is dead and gone you're gonna have
income freed up and from there you guys
can decide okay obviously we've got to
get you know some savings put aside but
you're probably gonna have some other
discretionary money there that it's like
if if they need help I'm not really sure
when you said first first generation
does that mean they just got here does
that mean they've been here for several
years like only you know that situation
um and you guys are gonna have to decide
okay what makes sense in our budget
what's a way that we can help them
by not also being a detriment to
ourselves I like the idea of staying in
that house at least six months and let's
get our feet underneath this and then we
can start saying okay what do we want
this thing to look like what kind of
help do we need yeah I'm with you man
there's something about that that
separation you gotta have some space
figure out at least the first six months
is at least preferably a year but yeah
man all right guys that does it for this
show thanks for listening and remember
when it comes to your life and money
y'all can tell me that that you won't do
it but never tell me that you can't do
it we learned before I can do all things
through Christ who gives me strength
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]